welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and james gunn's suicide squad was
a bloody goddamn delight of a film with
the finale that despite warnings to not
get attached
leaves us feeling latched to these folks
tighter than a starro to the face now
spoiler warning before i continue i
cannot beg you enough to watch this
movie in full
it's streaming on hbo max or better yet
if you can manage it see it in the
theater it's how god intended us to see
the nanoways kills
okay the suicide squad has two
post-credits scenes but to best
appreciate them and
final moments just a quick reminder of
what went down and real quick be sure to
check out our suicide squad inspired
merch designs our bad company shirt and
a king
shark jaws shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com more details on those
later okay so as expected the film opens
in a complete bloodbath at least on the
south beach of courtois maltese and
weasel appears to drown
but truly the first to die is blackguard
followed by captain boomerang and mongal
javelin tdk and then savant gets his
head blown off by waller when he deserts
rick flag ends up with soul series
militant group harley quinn with the
presidente sylvia luna whom she
kills and needs no rescuing from the
group of bloodsport peacemaker
redcatcher 2 polkadot man king shark
and milton and they learned from the
thinker that their intended mission of
destroying all evidence related to
operation starfish in which astronauts
abducted starro the conqueror who ended
up in the jotunheim lab on corta monteze
but waller's
real mission for them was to cover up
the american involvement in this
operation
and it all comes together in an insane
final battle against
starro the conqueror with every player
getting their own beautiful redemption
in the way they slay this beast
ratcatcher 2
beacons thousands of rats with
taikuatiti cameoine as her father the
original rat catcher who hits us with a
deeper theme
rats are the lowliest and most despised
of all creatures my love
if they have purpose so do we oh
all this with the perfect music from
composer john murphy a track he calls
raptism
bit a word play for the way this moment
doubles as some immersion therapy
slash a baptism for the rat phobic
bloodsport as the voices of a children's
choir ring out to give these lowly
creatures their own humanity
and by the way this after polka dot man
hilariously visualizes starro as his
mother and
as he wished to die back during the
briefing he meets his
end harley quinn finally realizes the
purpose of javelin's javelin and spears
starro in the eye but really it's the
rats who
gnaw away at his nerves and vessels and
brain tissue to bring him down
and this moment i loved its own kind of
tragedy for starro who speaks its dying
words through the general
i was happy floating
staring at the stars just a reminder
that starro was another victim
dragged into this now look when you're
doing things like packing for a vacation
you want to keep things light and
flexible like tom holland well thanks to
bessie for sponsoring this video
bessie's shoes come in handy for light
packing they're not only super light at
only 175 grams but they're also the
perfect everyday
shoe bessie makes these knit sneakers
that are 100 waterproof whether your
vacation involves
beaches or lakes rain or a very
aggressive cousin with a water gun
these shoes are taking good care of you
they're made with this dimetex material
that keeps your feet warm in cold
weather but cool in warm weather and
it's super easy to clean with just a
rinse of water
let's get them through their grass
swallow them drink them oh
no i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are bone
dry
like the dune sea thanks bessie
whatever your summer adventure plans
bessies should be in your suitcase get
them while they still have sizes and you
can thank me later check them out in the
link below and use my code new rockstars
to get 25
off your vessy's shoes the final shot
leaves us with bloodsport and rhett
catcher 2's longtime rat whom he always
hated but now anxiously pets it
showing how he is starting to get over
how his father tortured him with rats in
a crate
and this moment parallels james gunn's
closing moments to guardians of the
galaxy
in which drax consoles rocket by petting
him in a similar way
but whereas that moment reflected the
guardian's deeper theme of broken things
learning to let
others help them the catharsis here is
for the one doing the petting the broken
thing
learning to show compassion for another
now the first in-credit scene comes up
right after the closing title card
revealing that weasel miraculously
survived coughing up some seawater
and scampering off with his sing-songy
grunts
now weasel is played in motion capture
by james gunn's brother sean gunn
notice how its eyes even look a bit like
distorted askew versions of shawn's blue
eyes
it also makes this a bit similar
structurally to the way guardians volume
2's first post-credit scene checked in
with sean's character craiglin in that
case
sean gunn also cameoed earlier in the
movie in bell reed prison as dc
villain calendar man with the months of
the year written across his head now it
is not clear how
exactly weasel was able to cheat death
because waller's screen earlier showed
him with the skull
icons suggesting they probably had heart
monitors for all of them but then again
he's also just an
insane creature who violates all kinds
of laws of nature so why not it's a bit
funny when you think about how weasel
probably still thinks the mission is
still
on but a bit terrifying when you
remember he killed 27 children
i expect weasel could return an hbo max
spin-off series
peacemaker which the second post-credits
scene sets up a lot more but again to
celebrate the suicide squad we have
launched new merch options including our
latest obsession bad
company including the lineup of harley
peacemaker bloodsport and more
we also have an awesome king shark jaws
t-shirt
we've got a ton of unique colors for
these and a brand new nerdy street wear
hoodie
and so much more on the way check out
the suicide squad exclusives plus other
nerdy fashion for the fashionable nerd
only at newrockstarsmerch.com
okay in the second post-credits scene we
catch up with amanda waller's two aides
john economos
played by steve agee who did the motion
capture for king shark and amelia
harcourt played by jennifer holland
these two helped turn on amanda waller
earlier to help task force x take down
staro
but here a doctor brings him to
peacemaker as he recovers
you realize this is revenge right waller
knows we double crossed her and she's
getting back at us by saddling us with
this
douchebag i heard he was sort of a hero
down in court to maltese
was that what you heard because not
quite what do you guys want him for
just to save the [__] world that's
all so
john cena and a.g and holland are all
confirmed to return in the spin-off
series peacemaker it's gonna be coming
january 2022 on hbo max
eight episodes all written by james gunn
who also directs five of the episodes
and apparently this series is gonna show
him just saving the [__] world now
earlier in the movie peacemaker's neck
was
nicked by bloodsport's smaller bullet
which first penetrated peacemaker's
bigger bullet as a callback to their
one-upsmanship in act one always hit my
target's dead center get them more in
the center are you calling something
more in a sense i use smaller bullets
what they go inside your bullet holes
without even touching the side but
apparently the flesh wound wasn't a
fatal one
also joining the cast of the spin-off
series will be freddie stroma
as adrian chase aka vigilante a district
attorney and crime fighter with rapid
healing abilities
and robert patrick as peacemaker's
father auggie whom waller actually
brought up earlier as well
his father was a soldier who trained her
son how to kill from the moment he was
born
meanwhile lachlan munroe is credited in
the series as larry fitzgibbon
who might be related to doctor pits
given in the suicide squad he was the
one who implanted their head bombs and
was actually
a cameo by suicide squad comic rider
john ostrander james gunn put fun cameos
like this
all over the film including mcu mantis
actress palm clementine as one of the
dancers in the nightclub
i really cannot wait to break down all
the details you missed in this
great film that should be on the channel
tomorrow follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow and subscribe to
new rockstars thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you